I wanted to find out who I am I wanted
to know what makes me me and that's why
I use in those jeans to get my pie chart
to find out exactly who I am
the most surprising result is that I'm
23 percent dumbass who stands
immediately when the plane lands knowing
damn well I ain't going nowhere I'm a
third people pleaser a third loud mouth
breather and a third teeter honestly I
thought that percentage would be much
higher because I love chewing on that
booty I am so excited to find out that I
am 52% woman who loudly and confidently
pronounces that Ellen Salman what can I
say I walked the walk and I talked the
talk why would the L even be there I
used to wonder why my wife and
girlfriend hated me now I know it's
because I'm 98% not ain't never
been and will never be the
other 2% man of God and I found myself
in the trunk of Diane Keaton's car on
Christmas Eve hot as a guy there's good
times she stabbed three people my
results oh yes this says I'm a hundred
and seventeen percent person who has a
short attention span due to the
consumption of hard drugs oh that's a
charge I'm 50% person who says axe
instead of ask must be my black part I'm
biracial and then 50% racists which is
why I made that joke about black people
must be my white half can I call the
cops on these results I'm only joking
harshly wall column lip balm I mean to
but tonight I feel the breeze is that it
goes and for additional 999 you can
trace your actual genealogy and find out
where you came from
is it a little heavy
are you for real why do I buy clothes do
this who did this in those jeans takes
the mystery out of what makes us this
way by using our unique DNA fingerprints
to answer the age-old question Who am I
who are you who are we oh it's because
I'm biracial this is highly problematic
but contextually very accurate in those
genes in no way affiliated with our be
artists genuine
[Music]